six dépôts jours jours sur le portugal
vous avez même résultat que l'on aurait
lui-même ce moment là même vaccination
qu'en france pas mieux c'est bien
d'enchaîner en svt sciences nat
vous avez aimé par le ver en a fait des
schémas pour essayer de nous convaincre
du confinement ça m'a jamais convaincu
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est que les
essais cliniques pour les enfants ça a
commencé en mars
il ya deux mois de recul c'est pas assez
et que sur la rn messages et les essais
cliniques
ils sont deux faces on est dans une
autorisation de mise sur le marché on
est sur des essais cliniques qui sont
pas et que c'est trop tôt florian mais
bien sûr et puis surtout pour les
enfants encore une fois il n'ya pas
d'intérêt donc on les utilise et un peu
comme je le dis du bouche trou du bush
piqûre voilà du bouche à seringue pour
pour eux pour les autres et ça c'est
inacceptable du point de vue éthique
morale philosophique
moi ce qui m'a ce qui m'inquiète
beaucoup d'eux et de pressions sur la
vaccination
moi ça m'inquiète énormément quand je
vois alors il s'appelle peter piot c'est
un virologue et lui se prend pas pour un
enfant parce que justement vacciner les
enfants tous les tout le monde
c'est le conseiller spécial de force ou
la fender laguiole vous savez la cour la
présidente de la commission européenne
et lui il dit puis résulte d'une formule
vaccination ou interdictions d'entrée
je m'attends à ce qu'il ya des
restrictions pour ceux qui ne sont pas
vaccinés
c'est pas salutaire le pass vaccinale
est à je suis pas d'accord avec cette
société là où il ya plus de secret
médical où on crée des différences d
apartheid entre ceux qui sont là il ya
deux jours avec et c'est dramatique
c'est à une voiture de civilisation dont
on se rend pas compte et derrière dans
ce pass sanitaire dans ce qr codes on
pourrait y mettre autre chose demain
ne rentrons pas dans cette société là ni
rentrons surtout pas et encore moins
pour les enfants on va voir qu'il n'y a
pas de morts et 202 alors ce qu'en
pensent les téléspectateurs qui vous
plaît faut-il vacciner les enfants merci
oui à 31% non à 69 %